ich sehe so viel größer aus dazu sich
von dem wir sind die besten freunde aber
nicht mehr zum kochen geht
hallo leute ich wieder mal waren
willkommen zu einem neuen test video
heute mein gott das sind die zwei
kontrahenten ist alle wir sind in einem
torten krieg hätten trockenen worten
talent das ist das was uns zu seinem
auslaufen wie da haben wir machen so
eine kleine pause erst mit dem selber
backen bei ganz ehrlich ist es 29 grad
reißen uns den arsch auf jedes mal
tagelang endlich den so kurz vorm finale
aber vorher hessen der alle torten und
ich finde wir holen uns vielleicht auch
ein wenig inspiration denn so machen ja
ok fangen wir an mit torte nummer eins
unsere erste torte ist ein klassischer
frankfurter kranz warum redest du so
komisch
[Musik]
er muss eigentlich so von allem so das
ist ein perfektes gefährt muss sagen
liebe butter aber ich mag keine
buttercreme irgendwie ist aber auch muss
sagen diese haben sie habe rechner
sie haben faktisch möglich spiel nach
butter oder kuchen also solltest du es
kam noch besser schmecken bewerten wir
die eigentlich ja muss was geben wir ihm
zwei von 2002 von 10 2 von sega schmeckt
mir gar nicht ich muss auch sagen dass
wirklich einfach man weiter mit dem
kuchen nummer zwei ist ein kuchen war
man beim pump am bahndamm traum schmeckt
immer so hält gesund mit viel zucker
meine diät quasi diese butter kleine pro
tag oder viel besser fielen
das schmeckt er mit frischkäse butter
schmeckt aber jetzt sind ich sehr würzig
ist ein witziger kuchen kennt ihr wenn
ihr manchmal kuchen ist und es ist
einfach so gut zu seinem ganzen körper
runter und dies soll hier hast du noch
ein paar mehr stoffe punkte 6 von 10 6
und 10 jahren
dadurch blieben die pfälzer auch das
hier oben noch so weiße schokolade das
ist ein süßes titel ja
und wenn der kuchen auch der vitrine
stehen würde und du dir einen aussuchen
müsste ist würdest du den aussuchen
nein alles klar tor nummer drei ist eine
schwarzwälder kirschtorte habe ich
glaube ich noch nie gegessen was ist
einer meiner ferien kuchen eia
das sah nicht ein bisschen muffig und
fruchtig und schokoladig zugleich komm
du darfst ja votum so dass die sahne so
lange so groß und flüssig bleibt
was so lecker was okay ich liebe sarah
glaube ich einfach lecker einiges
erlebnis bewertung 8 von 10 bis 16 uhr
zuhause 5
als nächstes haben wir eine sachertorte
waka passiert auch wieder viel ich habe
auch noch nie ne sache tore gelangen
guck mal das marzipan schicht unter der
showgeschichte
[Musik]
mama und papa ich liebe mein gott was
rauskommt geil knackiger schoko toppen
indem alle diese tricks boden geiler
vorgestellt exciting vorstellen dem
marzipan
damit kann man dann auch viele früchte
jedoch um mehr wir das ganze noch
bisschen so matschiger machen
es hat irgendwie sowie einen kuchen mit
marmelade ein gestrenger wollte mir ist
die schokoladen schicken wir sind zu
hart nächsten punkte
zwei so schlecht der look hat mir
irgendwie mehr versprochen als es immer
ein bisschen wie bei dir vielleicht weil
man aber immer so erwartet die trasse
das ist so ein hässliches entlein unter
allen torten wir haben
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich bin so kelly halle berry cheesecake
also der kommt dem was wir gemacht haben
[Musik]
karamellisieren sind spekulatius keks
bodenmann avatar fiel irgendwie was man
luftigere slayer fall weil man schmeckt
den boden in der kombination auch nicht
weil das hier viel zu harry ist des
gastes
ich habe das auch nicht mehr probieren
aber ich habe trotzdem geben wir von
ziehen als nicht meine kugeln haben wir
einen afrikas kleckern sie da auch serie
perfekt cool aus einmal das soll das
sieht so ein bisschen aus wie ein eigelb
hier oben ja auch dass ich es so dass
anwender des klosters von mein ding so
stellt man sich das jahr an java 8 und
die perfekte kommen dann so das fruchtig
leicht und schwer
ich glaube wir lernen die schon viel
über torten weil das gewicht einer torte
ist sehr ausschlaggebend verschiedene
zutaten haben verschiedenes gewicht sehr
lecker können wir festhalten oder flac
oder auch 885 zähler hammer
eine david schepers ist geschockt was
ist das hier oben ist ich glaube das ist
der normale die normale torte hier
und dann haben wir oben drauf noch mal
stücke von der torte einzelne kleine
quadrat gemachte die obendrauf gelegt
haben und dann alles schokoladige ja
geil ich im reebok noch auf torte kommen
lasse ich liebe torte ebene besser warum
so viel auch wenn wir warten
schokoladiger das ergebnis und kriegt
man so fest klausur gefühlt es zu viel
könnte ein bisschen fluffige sein fündig
und die schokoglasur ein bisschen
leichter geht's wieder ins gewicht das
gewicht ist ja sie erschlägt einen preis
ab und besuchen
aber wenn du dir vorstellst die sender
kombination mit dem kaffee lässt ich
gebe diesen kuchen ja
schon sechs man sollte mit rouladen ich
übertreibe nicht wenn ich noch wenig
gesehen ich nach umfragen ja tatsächlich
schon okay
darf es ein stachel
ich hasse beleben
was ist es an geplant oder was es ist
einfach nachweisen
wir sehen aber sieht cool weil sie so
knusprig glitschig und schau mich
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
niemand
aber es ist so eklig ist die vergammelt
es ist es ein weißt schon ein bisschen
[Musik]
sagen fragte ob er nicht mal ich hab das
ist ein bisschen fluffige riesen
knuspriger rein was ist dieser
beigeschmack der uns beide wirklichen
kreis gegeben hat wird es sein
ich glaube es schmeckt nach all diesen
kuchen ich wollte einfach zu nehmen und
aus meinem fenster von diesem trauma
muss ich mich erstmal erholen wenn man
kurz pause beruhigt haben wir uns noch
nicht reden über diesen kugel ist sehr
wohl obst in dem kuchen und deswegen
haben wir jetzt einen komplett ohne obst
hier haben wir eine tiramisu torte und
die muss jetzt wirklich und sogar als er
im actros über die sind sehr ich mach
matschige torten habe ich festgestellt
wie matsch es für dich was ist ein
extrem tiramisu ist kaffee und
mascarpone creme gut aus hier immer nur
die scharf stellt hallo hier ist unsere
beste bewertung neun von zehn jahren ein
container der geilste muss nicht meinen
kaffee dazu trieben das hat und du hast
du bist da geht auch mal so er ist
einfach weg er ist leicht davon wird
einem schlecht hat man das gefühl
nicht zu süß verbesserte bittet zu
kuchen nummer zehn torten der wichtigste
kuchen von allem glaubt mir
der wird euch umhauen die absolute lusa
tor
weißt du erlaube es sieht aus wie die
versucht es zu machen
das ding ist nur weiße was es ist die
anderen torten vorher sind instagram
mache man auch so einem influenza partie
und das sind wir achten jetzt brauchst
dann auch noch vorbei ist kommen die
klassische becker torte einfach und ich
konnte türkei sondern so becker in der
kaninchen da bietet aber auch kuchen an
aber sympathisch ich muss auch sagen die
fand ich so abhängig andere die wird hat
den ersten blick keine aussage
aber naja stimmt die fakt eigentlich ab
es ist wie im wahren leben ja gesehen
vielleicht nicht so aus aber einzelne
solide hinsicht ist ja auch quadratische
am anfang die erste die wir gemacht
haben bayern kommt fix boden kuchenteig
darüber noch geniale idee als basis
dieses weiße pudding kann man nichts
falsch und massenszenen merken wir
müssen wir uns selbst auch mal treu
bleiben und uns die wir die erdbeer
schnitte ist der klassische gewinner
hält was sie verspricht irgendwie du
erwartest auch nicht so viel davon kann
man vertrauen
damit beginnt der fal'cie kelly noch
nicht kennt
sie hat auch youtube channel sehen uns
dann beim nächsten mal wieder haben wir
ziemlich findet habt ihr wahrscheinlich
schon im nächsten letzten video gesagt
dass weder den wir sehr gespannt
willst du noch ein paar letzte worte
sagen glaube da zuckerschock ist vorbei
ich bin es müde und
[Musik]